the special counsel gets aggressive and
President Trump takes on joint defense
agreements with former staffers but
while the mainstream media focus on
trivial details we will turn the focus
back onto the Special Counsel
investigation and ask nine questions
that robert muller must answer to prove
that his investigation is anything more
than the partisan hit job that it
appears to be then President Trump
threatens to shut down the government
over the border wall great idea
Democrats try to paint Ivanka Trump as
Hillary Clinton I'll abstain from the
obvious jokes that come from that
headline Texas mother tries to castrate
her son and John Bolton sheds some
sanity on the killing of Jamaal
khashoggi a lot to get to I'm Michael
Knowles and this is the Michael Nolt
show
[Music]
only when I am on the road and it is
very inconvenient for me do the news
headlines just explode there is so much
more out here with the Bob Muller
investigation and a lot of questions for
him
that Republicans and conservatives
should start asking we should stop
defending start going on the offense
I'll have nine questions that he has to
answer but first let's make a little
money with Mint mobile there is nothing
better about the holiday season than
unwrapping a brand new phone that isn't
that just the best until you get hit
with a terrible brand new monthly phone
bill which is always about 7,000 times
more expensive than you ever bargained
for
big wireless providers can really suck
the joy out of the holidays so this year
don't just upgrade your phone upgrade
your wireless provider switch to mint
mobile for a limited time
mint Mobile is offering the best holiday
deal and Wireless you've ever seen three
months of service for only 20 bucks that
is not a joke that is this is a $20 sale
for three months this is a limited time
offer do it right now I think I spend on
when I had big wireless companies I
spent about $20 a second I think what
though after all of the charges that
they add in min Mobile's holiday deal is
only here for a limited time it you use
your own phone with any mint mobile plan
you keep your old number all of your old
contacts mint mobile runs on the
nation's fastest most advanced LTE
network if you're not 100% satisfied
mint mobile has you covered with their
seven day money back guarantee it's an
amazing program and even at their
regular price it is it will save you so
much money it's just no hidden fees no
nothing you pay for what you want you
don't get stuck in these insane
unlimited plans where you don't use any
of your data it's a great great deal do
it you will save yourself a ton of money
take advantage of the mint mobile
holiday deal before it's gone three
months of wireless for 20 bucks get the
plan ship to your door for free by going
to mint mobile comm /co feffy free with
qoph fa c OV e fe fe that is mint
mobile.com slash go FF IC OV e fe e fe
three months of service for 20 bucks why
are you even still listening to me go
over there and get this deal mint mobile
comm / co f fi co v fe e fe maybe you go
get the do you know you pull over you
put the deal you type it in you'll do it
you'll do it after we explain what's
going on with this Muller investigate
what they are trying to do is just
totally confuse you with a bunch of
ridiculous unnecessary details and
meaningless trivial interpersonal
relationships among Roger stone and Paul
Mann afford and this guy and that guy
and Jerome Corsi and all of this and so
you get this deluge of headlines from
CNN or wherever and you think oh gosh I
don't know what's happening but you know
this side has a point and that side as a
point we'll see where the investigation
goes this is their strategy all of the
questions that are being asked right now
should be asked of the Indus pencil
rather of Bob molar what is the issue
right now just to clear it up the Muller
investigation is getting very aggressive
there is word that's been leaked to the
press of a joint defense agreements
between Jerome Corsi and Donald Trump
that right-wing writer and journalist
and sort of conspiracy theorist Jerome
Corsi and Donald Trump of agreements
where Paul Manafort now is apparently
briefing the Trump team on what Muller
has been asking him you'll remember a
little while ago Paul Manafort former
Trump campaign Chairman entered into a
plea agreement with the special counsel
so he said he'd cooperate in exchange
for getting out of jail a little bit
early now we find out it seems that the
man-of-war team has been briefing the
Trump legal defense team on all of the
questions and all of the tactics that
Bob Muller is using so Paul Manafort
classic Washington lobbyist looks like
he's playing both sides right now when
it came at the Paul Manafort entered
into a plea agreement I was a little
confused Paul Manafort seemed like the
kind of guy especially with the name
like monteforte you know he's the kind
of guy who will deny till you die he
does want to be a rat he doesn't want to
turn on his friends he's been a GOP
operative since he was in the womb since
the 70s and 80s so I was a little
surprised now it looks like he actually
was feeding some information to the
Trump team so that's pretty interesting
they're gonna try to blow this out of
proportion and say that a joint defense
agreement between one guy being
investigated and another guy being
investigated is nefarious and it's wrong
and it's illegal and not none of that is
true this is a very common occurrence
especially when the same prosecutor is
going after a bunch of different people
very common and it looks like that's
what's happening here
so what is the issue why why do they
need these joint defense agreements to
catch you up we went through this a
little bit yesterday right now Roger
stone long time GOP operative and
adviser to Donald Trump Roger stone is
under fire because he tweeted out quote
trust me it will soon be Podesta's time
in the barrel referring to John Podesta
the head of the Hillary Clinton campaign
he tweeted that out one week before
WikiLeaks released John Podesta is
hacked emails so now the spotlight is on
Roger stone it's on Roger stones
confidence jerome corsi other people he
worked with over how he knew that
WikiLeaks had those hacked emails now
what Roger stone is saying is he knew
that with that John Podesta would get
his because jerome corsi had written a
memo about john Podesta's lobbying work
so what Roger stone is saying is oh that
tweet and Podesta's time in the barrel
that doesn't refer to hacked emails that
refers to all of his nefarious lobbying
work that's going to eventually land him
in hot hot water jerome corsi says this
is BS course he says that nine days
after stone sent that tweet
drudger stone called asking for a back
story he said jerome you got to help me
out they're gonna go after me for this
wikileaks tweet make up a memo about
John Podesta that I can say was what I
was referring to in the tweet okay
that's what course he says Roger stone
typically denies this and he says that
jerome corsi is just contradicting Roger
stone because he's being squeezed so you
got these two guys one who was a trump
advisor for a long time another guy
who's a more fringy right-wing figure
who's met Trump I guess a couple of
times neither of them are especially
trustworthy
so you've got to read between the lines
and and really their trustworthiness is
beyond the point because the fact that
the Muller investigation is going after
them is the real issue here why what's
at stake why they're not going after
Democrats but just listen to the
language so this is jerome corsi in his
denial he says quote what i construct
and what i testified to the grand jury
was I believed I was creating a cover
story for Roger because Roger wanted to
explain this tweet okay and that's not
what I construct and what I testified to
the sir he's not he's not emphatically
saying this is what happened he's saying
what I construct that's a curious choice
of words maybe he's not telling the
whole story Roger stone for his part
says this quote I steadfastly maintained
that jerry jerome corsi
who had been researching the Podesta
brothers brought their business dealings
to my attention and that is what
prompted my tweet now that is a true
statement it's a true statement that
Roger stone steadfastly maintains this
the question is is it true is Roger
stone telling the truth when he
maintains that the construction of that
sentence also a little mealy mouth with
the words we have what I construct okay
that's true and what I steadfastly
maintained okay that's true who's
telling the truth we don't know listen
to this from jerome corsi though he says
later on by the way the special council
knew that I was creating a cover story
for Roger they can virtually tell my
keystrokes on that computer so clearly
they took joram course his computer
they're saying this document was created
on this date they can tell we was doing
he's he's been now under investigation
for a while I do not bring this up to go
after jerome corsi or Roger stone they
can take care of themselves would I
bring this up too as a preface to is why
are we even talking about these guys in
the first place why are we talking about
Roger stone and jerome corsi
conservative writers the media figures
we're talking about them because Donald
Trump won the presidency and he wasn't
supposed to Hillary was supposed to win
they had all decided it the FBI decided
it Peter struck decided Hillary was
supposed to win Obama said Hillary was
supposed to win the administrative state
they were that's what was supposed to
happen and then Donald Trump came in and
messed up their plans and then Donald
Trump won and now we've got endless
investigations into figures who were
peripheral who were at was ancillary to
the campaign who were they're just
digging for anything to get these
guys to punish them for committing the
unforgivable sin of working for Donald
Trump so that's fine what one issue here
is that even in the conservative media
people are harping on this I mean we've
got to cover it this is a major story
you got to talk but people are spending
all of their time talking about it
they're not spending any of their time
talking about Bob Muller or the FBI or
the Obama appointed officials who were
going in they're going after Trump from
the early days of the campaign why not
why aren't we doing that you know Ronald
Reagan said if you're if you're
explaining you're losing what he means
by that is if you're on defense if
you're playing political defense and
you're just answering the allegations of
the other side you are losing because
you're playing on their turf you're
playing by their rules and they're gonna
get you the classic political line is
when did you stop beating your wife
excuse me senator when did you stop
beating your wife any answer you give
justifies their premise don't we
shouldn't do that
so I have nine questions for Robert
Muller and the special counsel because
this this Special Counsel investigation
stinks to high heaven the whole Russian
investigation stinks to high heaven and
they need to answer nine questions
before we can conclude that this is not
just the partisan hit job that it
certainly seems to be here's the first
question may 23rd 2016 associate Deputy
Attorney General
Bruce ORS wife Nellie or goes on the
payroll of fusion GPS you'll remember
fusion GPS is the political shop behind
the steal dossier that dossier with all
that scintillating false information
about Donald Trump so Nellie or the wife
of the associate Deputy Attorney General
Bruce or is working on anti-trump
opposition research Bruce or did not
disclose this major conflict of interest
why not
why didn't he disclose it did he forget
did it not occur to him that this was a
major conflict of interest did fusion
GPS know who Nellie or was I think she
they probably did her last names or
first question why did they not did he
not disclose that second question may
2016 low-level staffer George
papadopolis tells Australian diplomat
Alexander downer
that he knows that Russia has dirt on
Hillary Clinton
then the Australian diplomat downer
passes this information along to the US
Embassy what were the circumstances of
that meeting why was George papadopolis
meeting with this Australian diplomat
Alexander Downer who set that up who
invited whom to that meeting what was
the meeting about what was the
ostensible purpose maybe George
papadopolis just like the cut of
Alexander Downer's jib and wanted to
have a drink with him or maybe there was
a purpose to that meeting on the part of
downer on the part of US intelligence
services or on the part of u.s. elected
officials maybe that meeting was a setup
I'm not saying it was I just don't know
what were the circumstances of that
meeting that's the second question third
question June 2016 the FBI applies for a
FISA warrant a FISA warrant is the
warrant that you need to surveil and to
monitor Americans they want a FISA
warrant to monitor four members of the
Trump campaign the FISA Court judge
denied those requests what sequence of
events led to that request and why was
that request denied
I might say oh well they didn't have
enough dirt the FISA Court judge didn't
think they had enough dirt on the Trump
campaign people okay well first question
why were they ordering it in the first
place second question why was it denied
and a lot of people don't know this in
the history of the FISA Court there have
been 40,000 668 requests as of the end
of 2017 do you know how many of those
requests were denied 85 at 8,500 and for
an 85,000 request a nine out of over
40,000 requests that were granted
compared to that there were only 85 that
were denied how come four of those 85
were this particular request to monitor
people on the Trump campaign that must
have been a pretty weak application that
must have been a pretty weak shaky
grounds to monitor those Trump campaign
members so if it was so shaky that the
FISA Court judge would in a very very
rare instance not grant the the FISA
requests
why why was the request made in the
first place who ordered that request it
is virtually impossible to have your
Pfizer request denied so who made it or
were the circumstances they didn't have
good evidence so what was that about
whisset political was in a way simply to
monitor the Trump campaign as it
certainly looks like good question thank
you Michael good question all right
that's the third question fourth
question June 2016 the DNC's computer
system is hacked yet the DNC refuses to
allow the FBI to examine the computer
systems why wouldn't the DNC let the FBI
examine those systems this was a hack
apparently hacking was a big issue in
the 2016 campaign the FBI has been
running roughshod over Republicans over
the elected president over his campaign
staffers why did the DNC refused to
allow the FBI to examine those systems
and why did the FBI take no for an
answer
the FBI has no problem kicking down Paul
manna Ford's door in the middle of the
night has no problem seizing Jerome
courses computer monitoring his
keystrokes so why would they take no for
an answer
from the DNC and what was the DNC hiding
I don't know but it's it it seems like
there are a lot of shady things going on
and a lot of rare occurrences obviously
shady things go on in the federal
government sure but it seems like these
are particularly shady so shady that
that they've drunk they drew the
attention of a FISA Court judge and so
on six question at July 2016 Peter
struck opens a counterintelligence
investigation into Russian meddling in
the election this this investigation
ostensibly was spurred by George
papadopolis meeting with the Australian
diplomat that was July 31st I believe
2016 15 days later Peter struck texts
lisa page about the insurance policy in
case Trump is elected so you've got
Peter struck he's not some low-level
staffer not some low-level FBI guy he is
the man he is the guy who's opening this
counterintelligence investigation not a
criminal investigation
counterintelligence investigation into
Russian meddling it's apparently based
on this bizarre meeting where George
papadopolis meets with a diplomat
the diplomat instantly goes running to
US intelligence so what is this
insurance policy what is that insurance
policy have to do with the meeting what
does that insurance policy have to do
with the investigation the timing is
really suspect and it stinks to high
heaven seventh question in September no
six question I don't know I lost count
my next question in September the FBI
hires the writer of that infamous steel
dossier Christopher steel the point of
contact here is Bruce or so you got this
guy Christopher steel
he's a ex intelligence guy in Britain he
compiles this dossier on behalf of
private clients on behalf of the DNC and
Hillary Clinton and other people and
then the FBI hires him in his point of
contact there is Bruce or whose wife
Nellie or is working with fusion GPS
which ordered the damn dossier in the
first place a lot of people sleeping in
bed together is it well literally in the
case of Peter struck and Lisa page and
figuratively in the case of Bruce or
Nellie or Christopher steel and the FBI
at this point I still think Bruce or has
not disclosed publicly that his wife is
working for fusion GPS so they hire him
and now is so at this point they've got
Christopher steel on the payroll why
don't why doesn't Bruce or disclosed
that his wife is working with fusion GPS
this at this point we can no longer say
oh he forgot oh it slipped his mind I
mean we could never say that anyway but
maybe give him the benefit of the doubt
at this point we certainly cannot say
that so why didn't he disclose what was
he trying to hide then on October 31st
Mother Jones that left-wing newspaper
left-wing magazine breaks the story of
the steel dossier until this point until
October 31st we don't know what the
steel dossier is we don't know about the
Trump you're an alleged tape thing that
almost certainly doesn't exist we don't
know about any of this this has all been
behind closed doors mother jones breaks
the story on the steel dossier October
31st the FBI almost immediately ends its
relationship with Christopher steel why
is that was that relationship not
aboveboard was that relationship a
little bit of a political hit job a
little too political insider E is that
what that was about
if the Christopher steel relationship
the formal relationship with the FBI was
totally aboveboard then why did the FBI
instantly end it the minute that that
became public timing again way to
suspect summer 2017 comes around the
inspector general discovers the Peter
struck and Lisa page texts these are the
texts between these two FBI agent lovers
having an adulterous affair with one
another who say we're gonna stop Trump
from becoming president we're going to
use the power of the state to prevent
him from becoming president only at this
point does Muller remove struck in page
from the Russia investigation now my
question here and we're told Robert
Muller is totally aboveboard he is this
unimpeachable guy he's a shark we know
he's a shark he's gonna he's an
excellent investigator he's gonna go
have he's gonna find every single thing
are we really then supposed to believe
that Robert Muller didn't know that his
lead agent the top agent on the
investigation had an end he didn't know
that that agent had an anti-trump bias
until he saw these texts until the texts
become public because he of the
Inspector General Bob Muller is such a
good investigator Bob Muller former head
of the FBI this guy couldn't discern
that there was something going on with
his top agent very hard to believe
really a little too much for credibility
okay final question December 2017
Andy McCabe admits the FBI wiretap of
quarter-page would not have been
approved if not for the steel dossier
you've got this F disgraced FBI agent
Andy McCabe admitting the FBI wiretap a
former Trump campaign aide quarter-page
would not have been approved if not for
the steel dossier which means that the
FBI using that steel dossier colluded
with the DNC in the Hillary Clinton
campaign which funded the steel dossier
and it means they colluded with the
Russians by the way because all of that
information that was in the steel
dossier came from the Russians it's the
only place it could have come from it
means that the DNC the FBI Clinton and
the Russians were in bed together to go
after Donald Trump who's investigating
that where's that investigation
we now we know that Andy McCabe FBI
doesn't X FBI agent now admitted that
where is the investigation into that
we're the investigation into those
relationships into the ORS in diffusion
GPS where are the those investigations
seem a lot more pressing than how Paul
Manafort was able to buy nice suits in
the year 2013 or how Durham Corsi is
gonna write another book on some
conspiracy that seems a lot more
pressing and nobody's going after it and
we should and this is all Republicans
should be talking about I mean listen
the the inner turmoil of whether Donald
Trump still likes Jerome Corsi or if he
read his book I I guess that sort of
interesting coffee shop conversation but
the real questions here are all about
this Muller investigation the prior
Russia investigation how it all came
about and who was behind it because it
stinks to high heaven and if Republicans
are smart they'll spend a lot of time
harping on now back to President Trump
back to non Russia politics I know they
know they're constantly trying to make
give this whiff of scandal all over the
administration that's fine they can keep
playing their little scandal games we
are going to keep pushing good
conservative policy so President Trump
has done a very good job obviously a lot
of conservative policy the one big
disappointment thus far has been the
wall I want the wall the wall has not
been built build the wall you you ran on
build the wall build the wall won you
the presidency so build it already
President Trump is now threatening a
government shutdown if the Congress does
not approve funding for the wall now
what happened Congress and the White
House have already passed most of the
fiscal year 2019 budget most of that
funding has already gone through what's
awaiting going through is funding that
relates to the State Department to the
Justice Department and to the Department
of Homeland Security the Department of
Homeland Security and the Justice
Department are the crucial executive
agencies that will deal with illegal
immigration and that will deal with the
wall Democrats don't want to fund the
wall obviously some Republicans don't
want to fund the wall
they're gonna hold this out they're
gonna try to make a big issue of it
Donald Trump says he's going to shut
down the government now conservatives
get squishy they don't want to shut down
the government they're very afraid of
all this shut it down they absolutely
should Trump is threatening it he should
he should do it he he actually said
about this he said I don't do anything
just for political gain but I will tell
you politically speaking this issue is a
total winner people look at the border
they look at the rush to the police they
look at the rock throwers and really
hurting people three people three very
brave Border Patrol folks it's a
tremendous issue and it's really needed
we have to have border security he's
absolutely right this is even if he did
things for political gain you know
probably people do that sometimes he
should do it it's a big big winner issue
and by the way the Democrats run rant
one the Congress this is our last chance
to get border wall funding out of
Congress we're not we're not going to
get it back
I don't maybe will flip the house in
2020 but historically speaking that's
unlikely this is the last chance why not
shut down the government over shutting
down the government is a win-win for
conservatives if we shut it down to try
to get good policy and we get the good
policy out of it that's a win if we shut
it down and we fail to get the good
policy hey at least we shut down the
government for a little bit works for me
because when you shut down the
government they they only shut down
non-essential services which always
raises the question why do we have
non-essential services why does the
government do non-essential things seems
to me maybe we could keep that shut down
permanently
the rejoinder to this is that if we shut
down the government that's also going to
deplete funding for border security
right now when you've got the caravan
coming through who cares I know it's a
bigot the caravan is a real issue
illegal immigration is a real issue
we've got now record-high illegal
immigration 2,000 people a day crossing
the border 2,000 people is a drop in the
bucket how long is the government going
to be shut down for a day three days two
weeks okay two weeks with 28,000 people
we have upwards of 20 million illegal
aliens in this country 28,000 people to
make a point to drive that issue own is
not is nothing I mean it's a drop in the
bucket
so and by the way if we shut if we shut
down the government and then people
start pouring over the border that only
helps us politically because people see
how awful that issue is it brings it
back to the consciousness and if it
works we get to build the wall that's a
win-win this is a no-brainer shut it
down we have much more to get to we have
got Ivanka Trump's emails Democrats are
trying to compare Ivanka to Hillary it's
not it's not a great comparison you can
I'm gonna I'm gonna be very polite and
I'm not going to tell the jokes that
write them said no I'm not going to do
it also a woman in Texas is trying to
castrate her six-year-old son and john
bolton is right about everything as is
usually the case but before we get to
all that i have got to say goodbye to
facebook and youtube if you're on
facebook and youtube I'm shocked you
haven't been banned you haven't been
kicked off that's good go to daily
wire.com if you're there thank you very
much you help us keep the lights on it's
ten bucks a month $100 for an annual
membership you get me you get the Andrew
Clavin show you get the Ben Shapiro show
you get to ask questions in the mailbag
you get to Oh get your mailbag questions
and we'll be doing that tomorrow you get
to ask questions in the conversation
that's coming up you get to even a lot
of stuff most importantly you get the
leftist cheers tumblr and that is very
important look the Muller investigation
is scary is going after Trump the
Democrats are all going after Trump
Trump is going after it's a little scary
but when that Muller investigation comes
back and they don't get anything they
got nothing on them oh you're gonna be
glad you have that tumblr you're gonna
need that tumblr go to daily wire calm
we'll be right back
Ivanka's emails oh no they've got us now
oh the demo you know the Democrat they
get so excited and every little stupid
issue they think oh we've got you now
they wear those shirts they say it's
Muller time cool cool guy
yeah look great it's yeah we got him
this is the end of the trump presidency
how many times have they said this is
the end of the Trump presidency
four four times a day since November 9
2016 now they're saying that Ivanka
Trump who is not only Trump's daughter
but a staffer in the White House is
guilty of the same thing Hillary
Clinton's guilty of because she used her
personal email account to carry on some
government business here's Ivanka
explaining herself I have to ask you
about your emails it has come to light
that early in the administration you
used your private email for White House
business your father had taken Hillary
Clinton to task for this so how did you
wind up in a similar situation well
there really is no equivalency all of my
emails that relate to any form of
government work which was mainly
scheduling and logistics and and
managing the fact that I have a home
life and a work life are all part of the
public record
they're all stored on the White House
system so everything has been preserved
everything's been archived there just is
no equivalency between the two things
there is no comparison there actually is
no equivalency they I think the left may
be genuinely thinks there is but it's
because they never understood the
Hillary Clinton scandal in the first
place the Hillary Clinton scandal is not
that she used her personal email account
sometimes to send emails virtually
everybody does that in the government
Donald Trump uses a cell phone sometimes
when he shouldn't use a cell phone it
carries it on him if people are worried
that people can listen in : Powell did
this he used a private email account
John Kerry used a private email account
but we didn't go after all of those guys
in the way that we went after Hillary
Clinton why because the email account
itself is not the problem if Hillary
were using a gmail account even that
wouldn't really be the problem the
problem is that it not that Hillary was
using a private email account
it's that she was using a private email
server when she was appointed Secretary
of State she set up a private email
server in her home
that would store all of those emails why
would she go to the trouble of doing
that it was a completely unsecured
server the emails would have been much
safer on government servers she did it
to avoid public disclosure laws she did
it to avoid federal record-keeping laws
she did it to burn the records of
whatever business dealings she was doing
while she was Secretary of State and
what business dealings was she doing
well we know a few of them we know that
the Saudi regime gave her at least ten
million dollars maybe twenty five
million dollars when she was Secretary
of State that's a bribe that is
pay-for-play
they gave money to that foundation why
did they do it because the Saudi royal
family is so charitable
out of the goodness of their heart this
Saudi Arabia the greatest exporter of
radical Islamic terrorism in the world
Saudi Arabia the royal family that just
chopped up that Islamist guy in Turkey
that cut him up while he was alive I
don't think that they're the sweetest
most charitable people in the world they
were paying to play they were bribing
the Secretary of State so what else was
going on we know that Hillary Clinton
was involved in approving the sale of
uranium to Russian interests while she
was Secretary of State
while her her foundation her slush fund
was receiving a ton of money from those
very interests what else what what else
was she doing we don't know because not
only did she avoid record-keeping laws
and federal record laws she then burned
the server she bleached it she
completely wiped it so that nobody could
get in there and look at those emails by
the way you can never permanently delete
any that's very hard to actually delete
files you know so another question we've
been told that maybe there are some
copies of the emails maybe there aren't
why aren't we getting those emails why
don't we why aren't we digging that up
we really probably should be digging
that up and she what she would joke
about it
she was so flippant she was asked by a
journalist a shockingly a journalist
asked her a tough question and they said
did you wipe your server and she said ha
ha ha ha what wipe it like with a cloth
ha ha ha no wipe it like with bleach bit
so that you can cover up the evidence of
your
option and the bribes that you took when
you were in our government that's what
it was the issue is the pay-for-play the
issue is the corruption the issue is
trying to hide from the American people
Ivanka's emails sent on whatever server
they were sent on are all there
we can find them you can file your
Freedom of Information Act request and
you will be able to get those emails try
filing a FOIA request for Hillary
Clinton's emails get back to me when you
got it let me know let me know how that
turns out in Texas in Texas a mother is
trying to castrate her six-year-old son
this is a truly horrific story really
awful child abuse and a bizarre
situation so this woman in Texas is
forcing her six-year-old son to pretend
to be a girl I guess the mother and
father are separated so when the child
when the son is with the mother the
mother insists that the son identifies
as a girl six years old when I was six
years old I was Batman six years old the
son identifies as a girl so now she's
forcing him to be like a girl where it
gets a little weird because I I have no
doubt that a six-year-old kid has
delusions we've all had delusions but
when the kid is with the father the
father is saying the thought that the
son insists on dressing like a boy and
going by male pronouns and being a boy
so who's telling the truth I don't you
never know and it takes two to tango you
never know if the mother or father is
telling the truth but we know that the
mother is dressing this little boy is a
girl and enrolled him in school as Luna
at age five five or six according to the
the father quote the boy violently
refuses to wear girls clothes at my home
and identifies as a boy so in this
situation you've got a six-year-old boy
the mother says he's really a girl the
father says he's really a boy how do you
think the courts are gonna come down on
this oh they might take away the
father's custody rights to the kid and
the rights to ever see that kid again
yeah of course because we're in 2018
because reality doesn't exist anymore
that's what's happening the the father
is being accused of child abuse for
refusing to call the boy a girl but the
boy doesn't want to be called a girl
apparently the the father is illegally
barred from discussing sexuality and
gender with his own son and when the Sun
is at his house he has to offer the son
boys clothing and girls clothing now
again this is where it gets a little
weird when the Sun is at the father's
house apparently the son always chooses
the boys clothing he doesn't want to be
dressed up like a girl but the father
still can't discuss it with him if he
discusses it with him you could lose
custody of his son or lose any any
visiting rights to his son rather where
is this all coming from the the mother
is forcing the little boy to go see an
activist political activist therapist
who is encouraging the boy to pretend to
be a girl and so is the boy what is it
is that the mother is a is totally
coercing the boy to put on a dress
sometimes maybe is it that the activist
therapist is encouraging the boy to
identify as a girl yeah maybe probably
but how do we decide how do we know what
the reality is here there's only one
guide to the reality which is the boy is
a boy he's not a girl period that's it
that's how we know the father is right
we don't know what the boy says to the
father we don't know what the boy says
to the mother we don't know what the
might we don't know any of that the way
that we know that the father is 100%
right and the mother and this horrible
therapist are 100% wrong is that the boy
is a boy and not a girl the way that we
know that this father should have full
custody of his son 100 percent of the
time and then this mother and therapist
should be in prison or in mental
institutions is that the boy is a boy
what do the mother and the therapist
want to do they want to shoot him full
of hormones prevent him from going
through puberty and ruin his life that
is horrific that should be a crime these
people should be sent to prison for a
long time at least or a mental
institution because you'd have to be
insane to try to castrate a six-year-old
boy and turn him into a girl he isn't a
boy he is a girl this is a big issue in
our culture it's real you know we make
fun of this
transgenderism etiology we don't make
fun of the people we suffer from it and
a grown man thinks he's a woman we don't
make fun of him
we have compassion for him but we make
fun of the ideology because it's
patently absurd we know that men are not
women we know that women are not men we
know that there is such a thing as
sexual difference we make fun of that
and it's very funny and we can laugh
about it but you know the rubber meets
the road when you're talking about a
little six-year-old boy whose life is
being ruined because of a horrific
criminal mother and criminal gender
ideologue therapists who are trying to
shoot them up full of hormones and
castrate them out were absolutely
outrageous and this is the logical
conclusion of a culture and Abbas a
society that indulge in delusion because
here's what happens this is how we get
to this point we are walking down the
street you know we're in 2018 everybody
is just really cool and if it feels good
do it and you know I just feel like this
man and I feel like this okay we're here
and then we all know somebody who I know
I know a couple people who have gender
confusion and they say I'm confused
about my gender I'm a man but I feel
like a woman I'm really a woman on the
inside and our first instinct is to have
compassion for our friend we say oh gosh
well they says can you please call me a
woman can you please use the female
pronouns and we say well I really like
my friend and I don't want to be mean to
him and if he's asking me to do him a
favor I'll do him the favor so on this
personal level I will call my male
friend a woman because that seems like
the polite thing to do it seems like the
polite thing okay maybe this polite
maybe it is nice but it's not
compassionate because when you indulge
in that delusion you accept the premise
that is not true that a man can be a
woman and a woman can be a man and when
you accept that premise then why can't
an 18 year old physically mutilate
himself a confused
psychologically afflicted 18 year old
boy
why can't he mutilate himself to more
closely resemble a woman even though
that surgery that mutilation will have
no effect on his anxiety on his
depression on his likelihood of suicide
it'll have no effect whatsoever
even though many people who undergo
that's
surgery have deep regret afterward a
writer Walt hire is writing about this
right now in the Federalist even though
why not why can't that 18 year old do it
what's an if an 18 year old can do it
why can't a 16 year old do it or if
actually though it's a lot what if we
could prevent puberty altogether and the
development of secondary sex
characteristics then probably it would
be much better for people who have
gender confusion right probably it would
reduce their rates of anxiety and risk
of suicide I mean it doesn't we have we
there is no scientific evidence
whatsoever that delaying puberty or
blocking puberty altogether reduces
rates of anxiety or depression or
likelihood of suicide in people with
gender confusion zilch is zero
scientific evidence but you know
probably that's true so shouldn't we do
it shouldn't we indulge in the insane
delusions of six-year-old children and
then have our six-year-old children
encourage them to mutilate their bodies
and ruin their lives and make a big
spectacle of it and then rob them of
their fathers because their father says
that the boy is a boy and allows the boy
who says he's a boy to be a boy that's
how we get to that point and it's not a
far leap so then when the left says that
the right is being uncompassionate
that we're not being kind to transgender
people that you know it's not it's not
kind to shoot up six year old kids with
a bunch of hormones and ruin their lives
and mutilate their bodies and confuse
them and robbed them of their fathers
that's not kind of either so if we're
talking about kind and compassionate and
nice let's let's be clear there now the
left-wing people who want to indulge in
this gender ideology I think most of
them have good intentions some of them
have bad intentions some of them are
true ideologue who want to abolish
gender altogether further on political
purposes most of them I think have very
good intentions they want to be nice to
people
okay the road to hell is paved with good
intentions and if mutilating a little
boy and confusing a little boy and
robbing him of his father because you
don't want to allow him to be a boy
you'd rather him be a girl and wear
dresses if that isn't the right down the
path to the very center of hell I don't
know what is
I want to end on a good note today and I
want to talk about how great John Bolton
is John Bolton was in a press conference
yesterday and he was asked about the
killing of Jamaal khashoggi
remember Jamaal khashoggi he is that
Islamist Muslim Brotherhood apologist
who was a Saudi regime insider and then
he came to America and wrote a couple
columns for The Washington Post and the
left are pretending that he is a
journalist and he was killed in a
Turkish embassy by the Saudi government
John Bolton has asked about this killing
about why he's not outraged why we're
not ending our relationship with Saudi
Arabia why he hasn't listened to the
audio tape in John Bolton finally just
gives us a little beautiful glimmer of
sanity here he is so let me take the
question of the tape first no I haven't
listened to it and I guess I should ask
you why do you think I should what do
you think I'll learn from it security
adviser you might have access to that
sort of intelligence how many in this
room speak Arabic yeah do you want me to
listen to it what am I gonna learn from
I mean if they were speaking Korean I
wouldn't learn any more from it either
well then I can read a transcript too so
you don't think it's important you hear
that I'm just trying to make the point
that everybody who says why don't you
listen to the tape unless you speak
Arabic what are you gonna get from it
really the president the president has
spoken to our position on this issue
he's spoken very clearly and that is our
position now tell me the other questions
absolutely right what a ridiculous
question they say have you listened to
the audio tape of the killing of Jamal
khashoggi apparently the Turks were
bugging the embassy or something so
we've got the audio tape and he says
well what would I learn from that that's
the real question he's asking he's sort
of telling a little joke and saying I
don't speak Arabic what but the broader
question is what would I learn from that
audio tape that I wouldn't already know
and they'd say well it was a brutal
killing is it yeah uh-huh well it was
you as is an outrage and for some reason
it's Trump's fault and we should blow up
our relationship with Saudi Arabia bla
bla bla bla bla
blah blah what happened because the
media narrative is that the Saudi
government this is what they want you to
believe the Saudi government killed
murdered in cold blood while he was
alive cut him up an American resident
they want you to believe resident is the
same as citizen an American resident
who's a journalist who just wants
democracy and liberalisation and they
cut him up in cold blood and this should
be an out we should go to war with Saudi
Arabia that's what they want you to
believe what really happened he's not a
journalist I guess technically as a
journalist and that he wrote some things
for the Washington Post he wrote some
things for different newspapers his
actual career Jamal khashoggi was as a
Saudi regime insider and unfortunately
for him a different part of the Saudi
royal family than he was alive with has
come up and he's have been a big critic
of the current Crown Prince of Saudi
Arabia Mohammed bin Salman
why is he criticizing him he thinks that
Mohammed bin Salman is too easy toward
Israel that he's too pro-israel he
wishes that the Saudi government were
more anti-israel and because since he
was a teenage boy Jamal cushaw he was
associated with the Muslim Brotherhood a
radical organization in the Middle East
that would wreak absolute havoc on the
Saudi Kingdom and on the entire region
so he was a regime insider he worked for
the regime he was a spy he's all these
things he hung out with Osama bin Laden
in the 80s there's a photo of him
holding an RPG in Afghanistan he wept
but he admitted this he wept over the
death of Osama bin Laden when US forces
killed him he's in his Lamas he's a
apologist for the Muslim Brotherhood and
he was killed by rival forces in the
Middle East the Saudi royal government
okay is that to say it's a good thing
that they cut him up while he was alive
that they assassinated this guy who was
undermining the regime no I'm not saying
that I'm saying it's par for the course
Saudi Arabia does stuff like this all
the time all of these Islamist
governments do they constantly are
killing political opponents doing
horrific things there's a there's a part
of of Saudi Arabia that's called chop
chop square because they behead people
there yeah this is
what's unusual about this the reason
that they're trying to make a story out
of it is because they want to go after
Donald Trump they want to pretend that
it's Donald Trump's fault there's
nothing new here what's the lesson
people been getting very upset because
I've been saying this is not a story and
this how dare you he was a person who
have compassion what do you think you
think it's okay no my conclusion is if
you pal around with Islamists bad things
are gonna happen that's that's what you
can learn you don't need to listen to
the tape of him being murdered you don't
need to listen to the tape of him
talking about how much he liked Osama
bin Laden you don't need to listen to
the here's what you need to know if you
pal around with Islamists bad things are
going to happen
that's fact-check true I once Snopes to
fact check that okay that's our show
today
I'll be speaking tonight at embry-riddle
I'm here still in Florida and then I'll
be flying back soon sir if you're in
town come check it out we can have a lot
of fun otherwise I will see you tomorrow
get your mailbag questions in in the
meantime I'm Michael Knowles this is the
Michael Nolan show
the Michael Nolt show is produced by
seniya Villarreal executive producer
Jeremy boring senior producer Jonathan
hey our supervising producer
Mathis Glover and our technical producer
is Austin Stevens edited by Jim nickel
audio is mixed by mic core Amina hair
and makeup is by Jeshua alvera the
Michael Knowles show is a daily wire for
word publishing production copyright for
word publishing 2018